On Isru Chag, our yeshiva had yeshiva on
Isru Chag and I was taking attendance in
the 11th-grade class on Isru Chag and I
knew that two of the boys in the
class had gone to Eretz Yisrael for Yom
Tov and yet I had perfect attendance in
the class on Isru Chag. So I asked
one of the boys, \"How did you get
back so fast?\" And he said, \"Well, I
landed at 5 o'clock this morning and came
straight to yeshiva. That's pretty good. Asked the
other boy, \"How did you get back so
fast?\" Said, \"Landed 9 o'clock last night.\" \"So
when did you leave Eretz Yisrael? \"Left Eretz
Yisrael on Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyos. So
he said the whole plane was full of
Jews from the Five Towns, from Teaneck, from
Queens, whatever, who were in Eretz Yisrael and
keep one day of Yom Tov in Eretz
Yisrael and flew back on Yom Tov Sheni
shel Galuyos because for them it wasn't Yom
Tov. So I was it got me thinking
about this issue, and someone had sent me
an email also asking me about this issue,
so I started to think about: is this
something that's permissible? Someone who's keeping one day
of Yom Tov in Eretz Yisrael and wants
to fly back on Yom Tov Sheni shel
Galuyos, is that permissible to do? It seems
to be that the hamon am has paskened
that it is, but we have to see
what the halacha has to say about it.
So in order to understand this topic, you
first need to understand a little bit about
what it means to be a ben Chutz
La'aretz in Eretz Yisrael and how many days
of Yom Tov one is supposed to keep
when they're a ben Chutz La'aretz in Eretz
Yisrael. And there are basically three opinions about
a ben Chutz La'aretz who's in Eretz Yisrael.
Most poskim, the majority of poskim seem to
assume that you keep two days, and it's
really based on a mishna Maseches Pesachim that
you take upon yourself the chumros of the
makom that you went to and the place
that you came from, and since you're coming
from a place that keeps two days, so
you maintain those chumros and you keep two
days even when you're in Eretz Yisrael if
you are a ben Chutz La'aretz, if you
are someone who lives in Chutz La'aretz. However,
there is a much-celebrated and publicized shita of
the Chacham Tzvi. The Chacham Tzvi wrote a
teshuva where he holds, in the teshuva is
in Siman kuf-samech-zayin, where the Chacham Tzvi writes:
Nireh l'aniyus da'ati d'tzrichim heima l'hisnaheig b'inyanei hamoadim
k'echad mibnei Eretz Yisrael hatoshvim v'ein zeh bikhlal
chumrei makom sheyatza misham, that a person would
keep one day if they're in Eretz Yisrael.
This does not get included in the general
rule of keeping the chumros of the place
that you came from because this is a
place-oriented thing; this is about the place. So
of all of the bnei Chutz La'aretz who
come to Eretz Yisrael, obviously they would be
they would keep only only one day. He
writes: V'ein beyad anshei Eretz Yisrael l'hosif yom
echad yoser mehakasuv baTorah l'hachmir af haba miChutz
La'aretz asur mehem linhog sheni Yom Tov shel
Galuyos. Not only are they allowed to keep
one day, they must keep one day. They're
not allowed to keep a second day of
Yom Tov. That is the shita of the
Chacham Tzvi. The majority of poskim did not
hold like the Chacham Tzvi. Rav Schachter likes
to point out that it seems that the
Chacham Tzvi has become more popular amongst poskim
in recent times, but that's the shita of
the Chacham Tzvi. It's important to realize if
you hold like the Chacham Tzvi, it comes
out a major chumra for bnei Eretz Yisrael
that when bnei Eretz Yisrael go to Chutz
La'aretz, so they have to then observe like
bnei Chutz La'aretz; they have to observe two
days of Yom Tov and would not be
allowed to keep one day of Yom Tov.
But generally, people don't apply the Chacham Tzvi
that way; they like to apply the Chacham
Tzvi in the other direction when bnei Chutz
La'aretz go to Eretz Yisrael to keep only
one day. And then there's a third approach,
or I guess you'd call it a third
and a fourth approach, with Rav Soloveitchik and
the talmidei Rav Soloveitchik have have an approach
where they essentially say Rav Soloveitchik said that
really me'ikar hadin he thinks we should pasken
like the Chacham Tzvi, that the Chacham Tzvi
is really correct and really we should only
keep one day. But because there's such a
significant amount of poskim that hold that you're
supposed to keep two days, so he thought
that we should respect those poskim by being
machmir for for two days. And that's what
they call the day and a half. It
doesn't actually mean a day and a half,
obviously, but it means that you should be
extra machmir. So essentially you follow the Chacham
Tzvi, you davon a tefillas chol on the
second day, you put on tefillin with a
bracha on the second day, but as a
way of compromise, you don't do any melacha
on the second day to be choshesh for
those that say two days. That was Rav
Soloveitchik's. Rav Schachter thinks the opposite way. Rav
Schachter thinks that the majority of poskim in
the me'ikar hadin is that you're really supposed
to keep two days of Yom Tov. So
that's always been the the majority. So you
don't do melacha on the second day, you
davon a tefillas Yom Tov because it's Yom
Tov, you say kiddush, you you do a
second seder, but at the same time you
have to be choshesh that maybe it's really
only one day, and therefore you should put
on tefillin on the second day without a
bracha, you should listen to havdala at the
end of the first day to make sure
that you're being yotzei for those shitos that
hold one day. So that's what people sometimes
call two and a half days, which also
doesn't mean anything; it doesn't mean two and
a half days, it means that to be
choshesh in that way. So those are the
three basic approaches. Most poskim seem... Two days,
Chacham Tzvi says one day, and then there's
various permutations of compromise or being extra machmir.
One day me'ikar hadin with a chumra of
two days or two days me'ikar hadin with
a chumra of one day. Rav Schachter just
added a wrinkle to this and he has
this very great chidush that he holds that
if you're part of a group and the
majority of that group is holding one shittah,
then the entire group is bound to that
shittah. So for example, he said he was
asked a case of a girl who had
studied in a seminary in Israel and now
she was back home and all of her
teachers in seminary told her that when a
ben chutz la'aretz comes to Eretz Yisrael like
Rav Moshe, like Rav Shlomo Zalman, like everyone
holds, she should keep two days, but her
parents and the rest of her family where
they were going to go for yom tov
now and they were going to keep one
day. So she wanted to know what should
she do? Should she keep two days because
that's what her rabbeim told her or should
she keep one day? So he said well
if your whole family is keeping one day
then you should keep one day because it's
a violation of lo sisgodedu to break up
in a single group to have people doing
some people doing one thing and other people
doing something else. Now Rav Schachter thought there
was a rabbi from California that was coming
with a large group of families from his
shul and he said bechol mikreh no matter
what I tell them, the majority of them
are going to keep one day anyway. So
what should the rest of them do? So
he thought also lo sisgodedu would determine that
if you're all in the same situation and
most of that group is following a reliable
shittah like the Chacham Tzvi to keep one
day, so then the whole group should keep
one day even though Rav Schachter holds me'ikar
hadin really it should be two days, but
lo sisgodedu would trump that. He has pointed
out to me that that's only if everyone
is in the same circumstance. What if not
everyone is in the same circumstance? Some of
the people in your group are there for
all three regalim. Some of the people in
your group own an apartment there. Some of
the people but you're in the same group
but everyone has different circumstances, so he didn't
think that that would be a violation of
lo sisgodedu for everyone to do their own
thing in that situation. But the real tricky
question is what defines a ben Eretz Yisrael?
Let's say you want to hold like the
rov poskim that a ben chutz la'aretz in
Eretz Yisrael keeps two days. But how do
you know if you are a ben chutz
la'aretz or a ben Eretz Yisrael? What is
the geder? So the pashtus is one would
imagine that it should depend on the majority
of the time spent. If you spend the
majority of your year in chutz la'aretz, you're
a ben chutz la'aretz. Or for example when
someone asks, hey where do you live? So
do you say I live in Eretz Yisrael,
do you say I live in chutz la'aretz?
So if that's where you koveia yourself, that's
where you consider yourself to live, pashtus is
that would be the koveia, that would be
the geder. But not everyone agrees with that.
Rav Shlomo Zalman Auerbach and Rav Soloveitchik both
held that if you are three regalim in
Eretz Yisrael, if a person stays in Eretz
Yisrael for all three regalim every year, and
not just Succos and Pesach because they're long
regalim, but really all three regalim, Shavuos included,
so then a person's always there for three
regalim, since this is a yom tov'dike din,
this is about yom tov, so if a
person's there for three regalim, that makes him
a ben Eretz Yisrael l'gabbei this and therefore
he can keep one day. That's how Rav
Soloveitchik held. The Gerer Rebbe had a chidush
that if you own an apartment, if you
own a dirah in Eretz Yisrael, so then
you can call yourself a ben Eretz Yisrael.
I saw in Piskei Teshuvos he points out
that someone who's half half, who's not really
sure, lives half of his time in Eretz
Yisrael, half of his time in chutz la'aretz,
spends a number of regalim in Eretz Yisrael,
some sometimes in chutz la'aretz, has businesses in
both places, he's really, could go either way,
so yesh omrim she'azlinan achar makom shenimtza sham
yoser, some say well you gotta figure out
which place are you there more often, but
others, he quotes other poskim that disagree, he
quotes the Shevet HaLevi and the Zekan Aharon
and some others that disagree and say that
you would go with wherever you happen to
be. So if you happen to be in
Eretz Yisrael for that yom tov, you'd keep
one day, if you happen to be in
chutz la'aretz for that yom tov, you would
keep two days. That is issue number one,
just how many days should a ben chutz
la'aretz keep in Eretz Yisrael and how do
we define a ben chutz la'aretz versus a
ben Eretz Yisrael. Issue number two is, in
order to deal with the plane question, the
airplane question, is what happens when a ben
Eretz Yisrael goes to chutz la'aretz? What does
he have to observe? Shulchan Aruch in Taf
Tzadi Vav se'if gimmel, bnei Eretz Yisrael sheba'u
l'chutz la'aretz assurim la'asos melacha b'yom tov sheini
b'yishuv afilu da'ato lachazor, that a ben Eretz
Yisrael in chutz la'aretz may not do melacha
in chutz la'aretz on yom tov sheini if
he's in a community, but v'chol zman shelo
higia l'yishuv afilu ein da'ato lachazor mutar, but
so long as he has not gotten to
a yishuv, he has not gotten to a
settled area, to a community, even if he
doesn't plan on ever going back, he's still
allowed to do melacha because he's not yet
koveia to be in chutz la'aretz. What does
it mean he's not allowed to do melacha?
Says the Mishnah Berurah se'if katan tes, va'afilu
b'tzina. assur, even in private he's not allowed
to do melacha. Rav Schachter told me that
there was an old lady, an almanah, that
used to live in his building that reported
to him that she had seen someone who
was known as a big talmid chacham, who
had spent some time in that building, turning
the lights on and off on Yom Tov.
And she said, \"I thought this guy, is
this guy religious?\" And Rav Schachter said, \"He's
a big talmid chacham. He was from Eretz
Yisrael because a family member was having surgery
in a hospital in New York. What do
you mean you saw him turning lights on
and off on Yom Tov? Maybe you saw
him on Yom Tov Sheni? She said, \"Yeah,
yeah, it could be that it was Yom
Tov Sheni that it wasn't Yom Tov. And
he was living all alone in that apartment,
he thought no one was looking, he thought
that it was... but she happened to see
a reflection off of a building across the
street that the lights in the... the apartment
was upstairs from her and she saw that
the lights were going on and off, she
was able to spot it. So that's what
the Mishnah Berurah is talking about, that's the
chochma of the Mishnah Berurah. afilu b'tzina, even
b'tzina, you think you're b'tzina, you're not b'tzina.
So even b'tzina you have to be machmir
not to do melacha. That is... that is
a second critical point. A third critical point
before we actually discuss the airplane: there is
a tshuva in Betzel HaChochma of Betzel Stern,
chelek aleph siman nun beis, where he discusses
what if you are a Ben Eretz Yisrael
and you are flying on a plane to
chutz la'aretz and you plan on staying in
chutz la'aretz and you end... so you land
in chutz la'aretz on Yom Tov Sheni. You're
moving, you're moving from Israel to chutz la'aretz
and you land on Yom Tov Sheni. Can
the kedushas Yom Tov start in middle of
the day? Or do we say, no, that
if you didn't have kedushas Yom Tov at
the beginning of the day, then there is
no kedushas Yom Tov. Can kedushas Yom Tov
start in the middle of the day? So
Betzel HaChochma Stern has four rayos from gemaras
that it can't, he rejects all of the
rayos, he goes back and forth for a
while. There's a very nice piece on this
in the sefer Ratz KeTzvi, Tzvi Ryzman from
Los Angeles in siman kaf hey, where he
discusses this issue in great detail. Generally speaking,
the poskim assume that kedushas Yom Tov can
start in middle of the day for one
who's... who lands in middle of the day
in chutz la'aretz, that it can start in
middle of the day. So now, given all
of that background, given all... everything that we've
just said, may one take a flight on
Yom Tov Sheni if when he's in Israel,
he only keeps one day of Yom Tov?
So the answer is, it depends. Why is
he keeping one day of Yom Tov? And
the truth is, a lot of people don't
know, they won't be able to tell you
why. They'll tell you that, \"I keep... I
asked the rabbi. I know which rabbi to
ask and I asked this rabbi and he
told me to keep one day.\" I asked
the Chabad rabbi because the Shulchan Aruch HaRav
holds like the Chacham Tzvi, or I asked
an Israeli rabbi because the Israeli poskim like
to hold like the Chacham Tzvi. Whoever he
may have asked. \"But I keep one day
because I asked the rabbi.\" So he doesn't
know. Is it because I own an apartment
and I'm there all shloish regalim and therefore
I think I'm a Ben Eretz Yisrael? Or
is it, no, maybe it's not because I'm
a Ben Eretz Yisrael, maybe it's just because
the rabbi asked... says that I should follow
the Chacham Tzvi. But let's think it through.
If you're following the Chacham Tzvi, well then
it would turn out that, yes, you may
be allowed to keep one day while you're
in Israel, but the second you leave the
borders of Israel, whether you're in a yishuv
or not, whether you're in a settled area
or not, the second you leave the borders
of Israel, you now have a din of
Yom Tov Sheni. And that's no time to
be on a plane on a day that's
a Yom Tov for you. Certainly can't watch
the movies, can't use the bathroom... I can
use the bathroom, just can't close the door...
you can't... maybe not even use the bathroom.
You can't... you can't... you can't listen to
music, you can't do anything. Not only that,
you have to make kiddush, you gotta daven
Yom Tov davening, hakafos shnios, you know, you
gotta have a... I can just see the
El Al flight that has hakafos in the...
you'd have to... it would be Yom Tov
for you. If that's what you're doing, if
you're a Chacham Tzvi Jew, it mamash becomes
Yom Tov as as you're flying. So that
would be a significant problem and that would
be not recommended at all. Let's say you're
a Ben Eretz Yisrael. The reason you keep
one day in Israel is because... someone told
you that if you own an apartment it's
good enough, like the Gerrer Rebbe, or like
Rav Shlomo Zalman and Rav Soloveitchik go there
for three... shloish regalim. So for some reason
you... you consider yourself a Ben Eretz Yisrael.
So if that's the case, so then lechora
it would follow the dinim of a Ben
Eretz Yisrael. A Ben Eretz Yisrael when he
gets to chutz la'aretz b'yishuv, he's not allowed
to do melacha. But in the airplane he's
not yet b'yishuv. He's not yet in the
yishuv anywhere, he's not near any community, so
he would be permitted to do melacha in
the airplane. But there's that third category. There's
not just the Chacham Tzvi people and the
Ben Eretz Yisrael people. It's that third category
of people who, which I think many people
are in this category, where they consider themselves
a Ben Eretz Yisrael while they're in Eretz
Yisrael. You know, that 50-50 category. The people
who spend so much time in each place
and have businesses in each place that it
wouldn't even ever dawn on them to keep
only one day when they're in chutz la'aretz,
you know, that they're just being machmir, you
know, b'tzina or whatever, they they absolutely keep
two days fully in chutz la'aretz. But when
they're in Eretz Yisrael they keep one day.
So that would probably put them meaning in
the point where then when they go to
Chutz La'aretz, it's Yom Tov for them again.
So being that there are all different types
of explanations of why people are keeping one
day and a lot of times people themselves
are unaware of why they're keeping one day
and it's fraught with all sorts of halachic
issues and problems and you also have the
maris ayin issue that people are going to
know that you came back that day, it
would seem that it's really not a great
idea for one to fly back on Yom
Tov Sheini, but it's more justifiable for a
person who's not following the Chacham Tzvi, but
for a person who's in fact following a
psak that he is a Ben Eretz Yisrael.
I asked Rav Schechter about this and that's
that's what he said also. He said he
wouldn't recommend it for anybody, but it's absolutely
not if you're following the Chacham Tzvi, but
if you're a if you hold that you're
a Ben Eretz Yisrael, then it's a little
bit more justifiable of why why one would
would do that, why one would be able
to fly on on a plane. Piskei Teshuvos
he writes, le-maiseh kasvu ha-poskim she-yesh limano'a ve-lo
likanes miyad well he's talking about if you
land already in in in in the airport
on Yom Tov Sheini. Case I was talking
about was the guy landed after. Although I'm
told that there were people that landed in
they had a stopover and landed in Turkey,
got on a plane and took off again.
So it's not just, you know, where you
could argue well I'm sitting on a plane
I'm not doing anything, I'm not doing any
melacha. I'm just sitting there. No, when once
you get on a plane then you're talking
issues of tchum, lemala measara there's no tchum
once you're in the air, but what you're
talking issues of tchum and you have all
sorts of different issues of carrying baggage and
all all that kind of that kind of
thing that's much more much more challenging. So
we would certainly not recommend it, but for
someone who's following the Chacham Tzvi, it's not
only not recommend it's really not recommended for
someone who's following the shita of the Chacham
Tzvi.